good evening
and welcome to uh
what i think will be an extraordinary
event which is uh
we're at the beginning of this uh very
important
creation of
dr arn president of hillsdale and it's
called the academy for science and
freedom
and as we know the pandemic and its
management exposed many
issues
beyond
infection
and those issues
include a
politicization of science the scientific
process has been damaged
and the free exchange of ideas frankly
is under threat in the united states
to combat that
we need to do more than just
frat about it
and so
dr arn and his wisdom
has initiated this new academy
for science and freedom
i am scott atlas one of the uh
co-founding fellows along with my
colleagues martin koldorf and jay
bhattacharya who i'm sure everyone here
knows as well it's a great honor to be
working
as a group with everyone here
and we have a particular
i have the particular pleasure of
introducing
martin kaldorf tonight as our guest
speaker
he is someone who doesn't need an
introduction but it's such a great
introduction i'm going to give it
martin uh was a professor of medicine at
harvard medical school
and for over a decade one of the world
experts
on statistical analyses
of spread of diseases
and surveillance
he was a consultant and on certain
committees of the cdc and the fda
and has helped with the new york city
department of health and mental hygiene
and as a member on the drug safety and
risk management advisory committee of
the fda
martin has developed statistical and
epidemiological methods
for disease surveillance
and
novel statistical analyses
for
indicating not just early detection of
disease outbreaks
but also a drug and vaccine safety
surveillance which is of
some relevance these days
martin
has developed statistical analyses that
are used today
in the cdc
and in places like new york city and
other health departments to monitor
kofit 19. he is truly an authority
on all of the things
that we think he might know but he is
more than that martin is really one of
the most courageous
people of all the colleagues that i have
come to know during this
pandemic i almost said during this
fiasco
martin
people may remember that i
received a
sort of a censure by a group of
professors at stanford university
medical school
and martin kaldorf was the only
scientist
in the country
who had the guts to go public and write
a letter to stanford
not only in defense of what i said
but specifically challenging all the
signatories
to a debate on the issues
needless to say zero accepted that
challenge to debate martin koldorf
so
it is really a great pleasure and honor
to introduce martin
as a colleague in this new institute
as a courageous and honest individual
and as a friend martin
[Applause]
thank you scott and
[Music]
for the to the kirby center and the
history college for hosting us both
today and
also
for this initiative of the academy for
science and freedom i think
science is broken and we need to build
new institutions that can help
save science
for the long term
i do a lot of
statistical and economical methods but
i'm sorry to disappoint you i'm not
going to show you a single mathematical
formula today
so
instead i'm going to talk about
censoring in science
and it's sort of a personal experience
and as
i tell you this story you have to
realize that there are other scientists
who had more
harsher censoring on them than than i
have had but i'll tell you my story
and then
you can sort of imagine how other people
have had similar stories
so
if you go back in history a little bit
two years
to march of 2020
when we first
heard the news
about this new disease outbreak in wuhan
and i was very afraid for for about 20
minutes
because as soon as this pandemic
hit italy and iran which were the two
countries outside of china who got it
first i realized that
we are going to get this this is going
to spread throughout the whole world
there's absolutely no way that we can
stop it
it's so contagious expressed without us
knowing about it
so that was very clear
and of course i'm a father of three
children so as all parents i'm much more
concerned about my kids than about
myself
so i wanted to know are they at risk so
i looked at
the vuhan data
which was sort of the only good data
available them and i saw this risk
factor that
while of course anybody could get the
disease
being infected there was more than a
thousand full difference between the
young and the old
and i thought well this is sort of
important information because it really
determines what strategy we should use
for this disease
i was no longer
concerned about my case they would do
fine
i was sort of in the mid group
and
of course for all the people we should
be very concerned and make sure that
they are protected
but i tried to sort of publish this sort
of simple calculations but it was
difficult i wasn't able to do that in
the u.s
and maybe it's that i only have 20 years
of experience as an infectious disease
epidemiologist maybe you need 30 or 40
years i'm not sure
or maybe it's because i was the only
professor at harvard university and
maybe they wanted a more prestigious
place
but i'm not sure why but i was unable to
do so
so eventually i posted what i wrote on
linkedin because i can post whatever i
want there after after three or four
weeks of trying
but because i figured that
okay nobody wants to hear this but it's
important actually that for historical
purposes that
that it's clear that there were people
already back then
who knew these things and you also was
the appropriate approach
of protecting the old but not shutting
down society for children and so on
so i put in the i asked to have it as a
historical document and
i'm a native of sweden
so i was reading the swedish approach
was a little bit different
and
but i was a little bit afraid because
there was a debate in sweden so i was
sort of afraid that the public health
authorities there who took uh
who didn't close schools for example
that they were buckled under the
pressure so i decided well i should
write in the swedish i published in
three operas in the two major daily
newspapers there was no public problem
at all getting published in sweden
and i figured that well if sweden can
hold out until the summer
then everybody will see that that was
the right approach and then everybody
will follow a swedish approach and
good
boy was i wrong
eventually i published it in english
also in a sort of obscure
uk
online magazine
so if we jump forward a little bit
it was sort of frustrating uh with the
difficulty of of getting one's voice
heard
and
i tried many different things i i
actually have managed to get into cnn
uh i write an op-ed for cnn espanol
because i know how to write spanish
the english version english scene in
english did not want it but i i was so
but we were trying to think how can we
sort of educate the journalists more how
can we get out this message and
scott was very heroically saying things
but they were always missing him he's
just one person and he is a radiologist
and blah blah blah blah blah blah and
other people were sort of dismissed
because there were one person or they
were not there was always something
wrong with them
and so there was silence so we figured
okay if the three of us me and
dr jay barashaya who is in the back here
and doctor gupta who is the in my view
the preeminent infectious disease
technologies in the world we got
together and we wrote the grant
barrington declaration a one-page thing
where we argued for better focused
protection of older high-risk people
at the same time as we let children and
young adults live
near normal lives so as to minimize the
collateral public health damage from
these lockdowns in other measures
well
that was
it got some attention and it got
enormously attacked
and every time i read an article about
it in whatever
newspaper attacking it they would always
have the link to the declaration and
says yes
because
then at least some of those reading it
will actually click on you actually read
it and
by now i think about 935 000 people have
have signed this declaration which
makes us very humble and thankful
the reaction from the director of nih
francis collins
was a hero to tony that is dr fauci
look at this
the proposal from these three french
ethnologists
you have two of these french
administrators here in the room today
who met with secretary assad who is
secretary of health the health and human
services
seems to get attention
there needs to be a quick and
devastating published takedown of his
premises
i don't see anything is it underway
so what do you think dr flauscher
responded
i am passing below a piece from wires
that depends this theory
i'm i'm sure this
journalist is probably a very fine young
man
but
it's a little bit surprising that dr
fausch uses him as the authority on
epidemiology
he's a journalist to typically covers
the climate food and biodiversity for
wire magazine
but
maybe he knows more than dr faust i
don't know about these matters it
wouldn't kind of surprise me but
here's another email a few days later
also from
dr fauci
he thought that
we were similar to those people who
denied aids a couple of
decades ago which is kind of strange
because
the purpose of the great banter
declaration was to argue for better
focus protection of those that are at
highest risk that was a major part of it
so why would we do that if we don't
believe covert is real so i don't quite
get the logic but uh
that's exactly what he wrote
so
there was an organized
campaign against the great barrington
declaration
with various sort of strange accusations
that it was let it rip which is the
opposite we were
thought
that we were like exorcism
eugenics clowns anti-vaxxers
that we did financial gains even though
the opposite is true
we were accused of threatening others
which none of us have done uh trumpian
libertarian cork funded pseudoscientists
and that would receive a free lunch when
we were
in great barrington uh
uh writing this declaration and one of
these is actually true
there are
there is such a thing as a free lunch
actually we do get actually we get two
free lunches there so
that was kind of nice they were good
food
other than that uh yeah
so
the focus of this talk is how samsung is
both direct censoring and sort of other
forms of it so
when the great barrington declaration
came up at the very beginning it comes
up top in the search engine google but
then suddenly it wasn't there instead
what was there was those who criticized
it
and the other search and you had it at
the top but not google and there were
some
there was some sort of discussion of
that and then eventually a week or so
later it came back up so i guess
but google always denied that they did
anything
there were some issues with cdc twitter
facebook youtube and linkedin so i'm
going to just tell you what was censored
so here was cdc in april 2021 so i was
serving on a
committee a working group for vaccine
safety of the korvian
and at one point
cdc decided to make a pass on the jnj
vaccine
because of some
issues of blood clots
and those blood clots was in
young women under age of 50.
but they decided to pass the vaccine for
all age groups so
i it was very clear from the data and
one of the things that i spent many
years on is to figure out how to as
quickly as possible find out whether
there is a problem with adverse
reactions or not using what's called
sequential analysis over weekly looking
at data and it was very clear to me that
there was a concern for women under 50
years
but there were absolutely no evidence
and there was actually evidence that
there was no concern for those over 50.
and those are the ones who really need
these vaccines the purpose is not for
the
the the young women or even young men
that wasn't the primary
beneficiary of this vaccine and the jnj
vaccine is sort of important because
it's a one dose so it's used it's good
to to to reach uh
hard to reach people like people in
rural areas or homeless people
where it's hard to get the second dose
so it's sort of important that so
i this
after
i sort of decided to
[Music]
they weren't quite interested in my
views on the matter so i wrote a thing
in uh
in the hill
uh arguing against passing this vaccine
for older adults
and then they removed me from the
committee
and four days later they they
lifted the paws but then the damage was
kind of made because
it already got a bad reputation and uh
even this was during the height of the
second wave so
so those who didn't get it that
some of those people died
so i guess i'm probably the only
person who's been fired by cdc for being
too pro-vaccine
in uh also in the spring of 2020 i wrote
uh on twitter
uh somebody was asking do you think that
uh young people should get vaccinated
and what about those of her cover
already so i said
no thinking that everyone must be
vaccinated as scientifically flawed as
thinking that nobody should
care vaccines are important for older
high-risk people and their caretakers
not those with prior natural infection
or for children so to me that's sort of
just
basic
ethnology nothing strange with that but
twitter has some
some people who have
who who i guess they they consider
themselves to be expert in this area
and they didn't like it so they
censored it
so that nobody could
share it or reply to like it which
basically means that pretty much nobody
will find it
later on they they locked me out for i
think about three weeks or so because i
tweeted about mask saying that
by claiming that masks are a good
projection some older people will sort
of
believe that and they will go and do
things and
they
get infected thinking that it protects
their way it doesn't
and
that's not so good so they might die
because of this misinformation about the
masks but i guess
that
made took for three weeks i had no
access to twitter because of this tweet
here's another one
i asked
there was an article published by
brownstone institute by
roberto strongman who is an associate
professor of black studies at the
university of california santa barbara
and here was the very interesting
historical expertise of how
mass has been used historically
for example to silence slaves
and
he talked about
anastasia who is a brazilian saint as a
former slave
and that was not popular
of twitter so that was also censored
facebook they took down the great
barrington declaration page for a week
no explanation
um the offending post was that we argue
that
with the vaccines which at that time has
just come out we should prioritize
giving it to the older high risk people
and that's what caused facebook to
close
close it down and there was sort of some
protest against it and therefore they
pick it back up against after week
but
that was the facebook censoring when
youtube
we did a
roundtable
in april with
governor
ron desantis in florida was me and
dr scott atlas dr j barashaya and dr
sneta gupta and we talked for example
about the fact that
children don't need to have masks
and we argued against vaccine passports
we sort of there was some rumbling
starting about vaccine past but then we
sort of started let's try to
argue against that from the very
beginning before it sort of takes off
well
so that was removed by youtube which is
owned by google
uh
linkedin which is owned by microsoft
they also censored this was an article
uh
this was an interview i did with epic
times and
[Music]
on the dangers of vaccine mandates
now
they are a little bit nicer i guess
because they
they only you can see these posts so i
can still read my post
but nobody else could so at least they
didn't remove it from me so
that was uh yeah
this was another one i actually didn't
write anything i just
reposted
a a
linkedin post by a guy from iceland and
what he did he just cited what the
icelandic chief epik knowledge had said
which is of the equivalent of the cdc
director in the u.s
so this is the official
public health authority in iceland
but that was censored
[Music]
here another one
here they were a little bit harsher
because not even i was allowed to read
this tweet i removed it completely
i was arguing that uh
since the people who have recovered from
kovit they are the ones who have the
best immunity
better than those who are vaccinated
so
the other ones are least likely to
spread it to others
so hospitals should hire
nurses like that or doctors like that
and use them for the most frail oldest
patients at the theoretic wards or the
icus because they are the least likely
to infect these patients
instead the hospice was firing them
but
linkedin did not enjoy that post
here's another one we together with
dr baracharya
we wrote a newspeak article about how
far she fooled america
with
the various things about public health
and
linkedin took that away also
but the
microsoft news
they actually republished it
so one arm of microsoft is censoring
this article because linkedin is owned
by microsoft but another part of
microsoft is actually
republishing it so i shouldn't be too i
guess upset with microsoft here but
it's a little bit so i guess they are
sort of
maybe this just sort of
skip it and just censor themselves i
guess or something like that
here's another one that microsoft or
linkedin didn't like i
sort of
during the ace pandemic we blamed the
sick we stigmatized gays we did fear
mongering we ignored the poor slow with
treatments
and
an iaid was headed by you know who
and during the core epidemic blame the
six stigmatized i was unvaccinated
fear-mongering lockdowns harm the poor
the most slow with treatments and niaid
is directed by you know who
so when will we ever learn
and hopefully one day we will learn
later on
linkedin actually
closed down my
my account
and uh
jeffrey tucker at brownstone he then
wrote an article about it
which then got tweeted so i never asked
to be reinstated but they did it
automatically so i think somebody at
linkedin read this what geoffrey wrote
and sort of reverse the decision so
this was the
last post before suspension
by firing staff with national immunity
after cover recovery hospitals got rid
of those least likely to infect others i
think this is sort of
[Music]
an epidural fact but that was the
that was the
the tweet that got me in trouble
so uh
twitter linkedin youtube facebook they
have permanently suspended many accounts
including scientists
and
i have
continued to speak up but i'm being i
have self-censored myself because these
are important
channels of communication so i don't
want to be removed so i'm careful with
what i say
and for a while i was thinking well i
don't really want to do that because i
should be able to tell what i want and
maybe i should just forget about twitter
and linkedin
and i talked to a dear friend of mine
who is also in the faculty
at uh at harvard and her family comes
from slovakia and her family was very
active
against the communist regime in
czechoslovakia her grandfather was like
one of the leading dissidents there and
she told me no no no no
you can't just walk away
you have to use whatever they allow you
to use
and then you just have to be careful how
far you can go so you can keep doing it
because
otherwise you let them win
so she convinced me sort of to
do okay i need to continue
using uh
these venues for communication
but uh censoring at least two cell
sensors and also it leads to
self-sensing of people who don't
are victims of this censoring because
they see that somebody else is censored
okay i don't want to be suspended
so i better be careful with what i say
and of course that's the purpose of
authoritarians
and the purpose of these things and
sometimes where they sort of kind of
randomly select
who they sense and what they sense
because they want people to be uncertain
about what they can and cannot say
but there are things that are ways to
fight censoring i think one is through
exposure
using alternative platforms but we
cannot only use that we also have to use
the one that reached the most people
and then some some guillotines maybe can
be used
so for example when robert malone was
censored
was removed from linkedin
other people were sort of complaining
about it and saying that it's important
that scientists can have debates
and
otherwise it leads to bad public health
and so he was removed from linkedin
and so i wrote this twitter thing and i
actually did a screenshot this morning
and if you can see there on the right
they are sort of suggesting other people
i should follow they think i should
follow linkedin which i'm not doing
they also think i should follow robert
malone which i would be delighted to do
the only problem is that
twitter has suspended his account also
but they still won't recommend it i
should follow him so at least that's
nice and you notice that
you notice that they removed his bio
when you click on his thing
but on the advertisements for his
account the bio is still intact
so
the alternative platforms and i have i
sometimes post on getter gaap parlor and
speaks
and i've never been censored there
there's also through social with this
new uh new platform
so i think it's important to use that
but i think we also need to use the the
existing ones
we can also try to make a little bit fun
with people so
once i wrote an op-ed
uh
with
in the hill
and i didn't feel i should just maybe if
i posted on twitter they were sensing me
so i said
well twitter doesn't allow me to vaccine
scientists to fill these classified
scenes but you can find out it on these
other accounts
if earlier this week
i said having been censored by twitter i
must be careful what i write about masks
and then i said if you do surgery please
wear a surgical mask you'll protect your
patients
and i think that's uh
nobody can argue with that no
you agree that surgeons should wear a
mask when they perform surgery you do
okay good we're all in agreement and
nobody can say that i said something
that was inappropriate
so
it has been really stunning to be a
scientist during these
last two years
uh it's kind of been absurd
we have an nih director collins and an
idea that fauci thinking that you
promote science by silencing scientists
through published takedowns
that's pretty
absurd
you have a geneticist and a biologist
thinking they know abnormally better
than acknowledged at oxford harbor and
stanford and calling them instead of
french technologists
we do lockdowns to protect young
low-risk members of the laptop class
instead
instead of focusing protection on older
high-risk people
this mistake led to many deaths and many
unnecessary deaths
um
where people pretending to care for the
global poor who favor lockdowns that has
caused more harm to the poor people
around the world than anything other
than war and slavery
that sort of be astonishing and absurd
in my view
uh
people have been accusing working-class
people who oppose these devastating
lockdowns as being right-wing extremists
they're just the one who has taken the
biggest brunt of these lockdowns and
they have lived
the experience of it
we had scientists signing a signing in
lancet
a famous medical unit publishing a
petition requesting national immunity
after curve recovery
something that we have known about for
almost two and a half thousand years
since the athenian plague in 430 bc
it's uh
it's not surprising that the national
immunity
is strong enough to cover it and that is
better than the the
vaccine immunity we would be very
surprised if it was anything else
we had a cdc director who believed that
face masks provide better protection
against cover than vaccines
and then another cdc director who
questions natural immunity after
recovery
we fire people with natural immunity
after cover recovery even though they
are less least likely to spread kobe to
others
cdc was firing me
as a pro vaccine for being too pro
vaccine
a big tech sensing apologies to get the
pandemic right while boosting those who
got it wrong as covet experts sometimes
people sort of said these are discovered
experts and there's
people like uh
who uh who actually are not even
even uh
who don't understand infectious
technology and public health at
and then we have cyril kovet and i won't
talk about that one so
so what are alternatives well we have d
base instead of censoring and slander
scott mentioned that i offered to debate
any of these was it 98 or so stanford
faculty members who wrote this letter
criticizing him and that invitation is
still open
if you know any of them let them know
that i'm happy to debate them either
here or somewhere else
we should have had discussion how better
to protect high risk older people
we should have much more discussion
about all these locked unharms the
collateral public health damage from
these
because public health is not just one
disease it's multiple diseases it's not
just short term it's long term
so
those are basic principles of public
health that we have to follow we didn't
during this pandemic
we have to trust public with honest
information
otherwise they're never going to trust
public health and science and that's
exactly what happened
there's a reason that people don't the
good reason why people don't trust
public health and science and
i think the academy of science and
freedom is one aim is to sort of restore
so we deserve that trust again
so
those were my
remarks
from the last two years and i'd like now
to invite up to the podium my colleagues
dr scott atlas dr jay barasharya and to
moderate
a quest a q a session here
jan jalyak from epoch times
[Applause]
so uh we'll jump right in um it's a
pleasure and an honor to be here with
these three american thought leaders
genuine thought leaders
um and we're actually going to do this
as a audience q a mostly so i'll just
get us started here and so
you know as uh dr koldorf mentioned
there were you know there's
a lot of alternatives to absurdities
that are that that were offered and
we've also discussed a bit um certainly
um in the epoch times and in discussions
i've had with with all three of you um
the the cost this collateral damage of
the lockdowns and i've learned recently
that in the
uk at least there were
a lot of counter indications like that
the government had information
that explained why not to do lockdowns i
guess and the question that i have is um
did this sort of thing exist in the u.s
and it was just either ignored or or
just sort of thrown out
so there was a paper in 2006
by don henderson who is the famous
efficiency technologist he was
instrumental in
eradication of smallpox
and which laid out very clearly that
lockdowns are not the way to go
and for a variety of reasons and
so i think most countries had this
sort of pandemic
plan so what to do and they were all
protect those who were most vulnerable
and try to have
a society function normally so
and jeffrey tucker wrote a very good
article just recently about the
brownstone institute about this don
henderson and
what he said in that
paper from 2006. if i may add i mean
this is something i don't think the
public understands that the
this is not news that lockdowns don't
work and shouldn't be done and are
extraordinarily harmful the standard
literature on pandemic management
before this pandemic was that lockdowns
should not be used because they don't
work and they're extraordinarily harmful
and the key paper that martin is talking
about
was really accepted this was a complete
change
in the accepted management of a pandemic
what was done
do we have a mic going around and let's
do a question from the audience right
over here first hand
so uh
dr polo thank you for your remarks and
the whole time i'm listening to you talk
about the way you've been censored
the question is why
what is it that drove what we've seen
over the last two years was it greed
was it partisanship was it fear was it
ignorance
what explains the way that we have seen
not just our government react with
governments around the world and big
tests
why
well i can start
um because they're they're it this is
always the most challenging question i
get asked this all the time why the
answer to why is always very difficult
but in this case
i tend to think that there was a
confluence of different interests a
confluence of different motivations
rather than this idea that there was one
major motivation to do this
and what i saw in the white house
gives me that basis because what i saw
was a combination of gross incompetence
tremendous hubris
by people who are protecting their own
status and positions at all costs
people with bureaucratic uh sort of
motivations that's my phrase really
which is not the same as the free
exchange of ideas and debating like in
typical science pre uh before this of
course there is a very complex web of
funding
science that one of this is one of the
things that we want to expose and then
fix if we can
where there are
funding streams coming from people who
are have a massive power
not just over the funding of the
research but of over everyone's career
doing the research and so university
professors who are assistant professors
are not going to really feel very
comfortable speaking out against the nih
when the nih is the
determining factor for their own career
and then big pharma and everything so uh
the second part of it though is that
they're i think we cannot underestimate
the fear
and i'm talking about the fear from
covid even in the people who are making
policy
fear uh is a very powerful distractor
from rational thinking
and
when there is pressure in a situation i
think we all know this in our own
personal lives your true nature comes
out your true character comes out and
this was a highly pressurized
environment of course the biggest health
care crisis in a century
during an election year which was
another motivation that i don't think we
can ignore the political side so when
you have people who are personally
afraid
and are motivated by extraneous things
it's a very very bad mix
particularly when they are intimidated
by people who have their own personal
names
on the proscribed policy which was the
lockdowns
and so there's no easy answer to why in
my view
there's a tremendous amount of
corruption uh and i mean moral
corruption not just financial
because the universities i'll give you
an example stanford university receives
over 500 million dollars a year in nih
funding there are some schools that
receive over a billion dollars a year in
nih funding what do you think the
likelihood is that those recipients of
that money can speak freely so there's a
lot of motivations i could go on and on
but i but i won't because they're uh
first of all i'm gonna let jay answer
but also because there is no real short
answer to the question so so i don't
disagree with anything scott just said i
think all of that is true but let me
just add a couple of notes to it so so
uh in particular about the emails that
you saw the absolutely shocking emails
you saw
from francis collins and tony fauci and
then tony fauci about me martin and
sunitra gupta
one of the motivations for that was a
motivation to create a consensus within
the public that that a an illusion of
consensus within the public that that
there was no scientific dissent against
lockdowns
the the reason why the the great
barrington declaration they reacted that
way
uh because you know the idea is i mean i
love them but they're like ancient i
mean martin told you like you know we
these are not the idea of protecting the
vulnerable i bet you everyone in the
audience had that idea during the
pandemic right i mean i saw
several people in the audience who like
very brave people who like spoke up
around this but the fact that we
were from harvard stanford and oxford i
mean i never cared before about coming
from stanford i'll tell you before the
pandemic
but from harvard stanford and oxford
and
we got this viral attention was a
problem for this group it posed a
political problem for them because they
wanted to tell the public that there was
no dissent
and so they had to destroy us
they had to do a devastating takedown it
was a political problem they were
solving uh motivated by some of the
things that scott was saying right so i
think um so i think that that's the
that's the immediate context for why
they they did what they did um
the other thing i so i want to i want i
want to be as charitable as i can be i
think they're
in science
the norm is we we frankly science
science is just another one for fighting
with each other in a structured way i
mean it's it's like it's really fun like
you you you know i have an idea but i
prasad has an idea we like fight with
each other and then there's a data
there's some some some like experiment
and vinai turns out to be right i'm like
oh damn for now you got right this time
um i mean that's that's what science is
is that's that's the warping move of
science it's like a discussion among
people who are
we're all equally
struggling with a difficult thing we
don't know the answer that's that's the
fun of science right it has to have that
that kind of norm of a fun discussion
with each other um
where we take each other in good faith
the norm in public health is a little
different
right in public health
if i
as a professor at ms school of medicine
get up and say smoking is good for you
i i've i've committed a sin right the
the scientific literature is completely
convincing that smoking is terrible for
you i should not ever get up and say
smoking good for actually you mean like
hint at it frankly joking about it right
now is probably going to get me in
trouble um
so
that's going to be an excerpt on youtube
oh god please no um
i violated a norm a real true norm a
good norm right because i i have a
responsibility because i i act in public
health and not crossing that line and
misrepresenting what's in the scientific
literature
uh that's that's a true north republican
so public health doesn't actually
encourage complete free discussion of
ideas
i mean legitimately doesn't
but the ethical basis for that norm is
that there's a scientific consensus
and when you have a novel disease when
you have a a situation where there's a
whole lot of scientific uh
ignorance because we just we just don't
know about a whole you know how does the
disease transmit who's really most who's
what's the what's the risk of dying if
you get the disease how best to treat it
you know so on and so forth um
well you don't have you don't have that
moral basis scientists need to be able
to talk freely with each other about
these things before you can apply the
public health norm morally
and what happened was that
the folks that martin showed you they
applied the public health norm before
the scientific discussion had actually
been done
before the consensus it happened and it
was it was an immoral act because they
they misapplied a legitimate norm in
public health to scientific free
discussion
can i add something to that because i'm
going to i'm going to disagree a little
bit a lot of the stuff was known in the
spring of 2020 that's true and
you know the first person that came out
with
saying that the
intelligences are you for not sorry
targeted protection was uh johnny and
needy's to my knowledge she's an
epidemiologist at stanford uh he was met
with a backlash and in march i wrote a
paper
on calling for targeted protection and
stating some facts about who was at risk
because this was already known there was
a body of literature in march and april
of 2020
and when i wrote my paper uh in march of
2020 asking for targeted protection i
sent it to the wall street journal
and this i'm naming them because i think
a lot of people think oh there's some
kind of a left-wing media cabal no it
really was much more pervasive than that
my re uh my rejection from the wall
street journal said oh we're already
publishing all this stuff on on targeted
protection
and so uh people because people ask me
why did the first papery rock go into
the washington times and i put it in the
washington times because it was rejected
from the wall street journal and it was
urgent
that this stuff was laid out that the
risk to it was known in a very uh
targeted group of people that we need to
protect those people that it's very
harmful to do the lockdowns
etc and so there was a enormous
amount of information known from studies
all over the world it was known in this
by the end of spring 2020 that we must
open the schools
known it was proven it was not arguable
the children had an extremely low risk
if they were healthy that most children
did not spread significantly the disease
and that there was enormous harm for
closing schools that was known
in the spring of 2020 and when you said
that
you were vilified and as martin
articulated here it was pointed out that
you were dangerous and that's how the
lockdowns
uh were in were accepted by the public
is that there were there were two things
done one was everyone who was calling
for ending the lockdowns was called
dangerous
because they were somehow therefore
calling for what martin said let it rip
heard immunity strategy no protection
which was a lie
and the second reason was they were
claiming anyone who was against the
lockdown was prioritizing the economy
over lives
yet there was a multiple decades of
literature showing that severe economic
downturns killed people
so the answer of ending the lockdowns
for saving the economy was because it
was lives versus lives so the everyone
on this stage
was vilified to varying extent and
demonized as if you were dangerous and
that is why in my view the public bought
into this even though it defied all
logic because when i speak as these guys
do all over the country
everyone in the audience says that's
exactly what we thought when i go
through all the data because it's simple
logic that you knew who was at risk you
do everything you can to protect them
and you don't destroy the people who did
not have a significant risk
now i'm really glad i didn't censor him
since i just learned something from him
you know
a super quick follow-up um there seems
it seems to be pervasive that there's
you know whenever
many important issues like this one
these straw men are created and attacked
and so how do you how do you
counter that especially when they're
amplified such a great degree
well i mean countering a straw man
argument
it happens when i was raising my kids
because that was our typical dinner
conversation
but you know honestly the solution to
all of this stuff the number one
solution to me
is
stopping the censorship and having
transparency of information you need to
think critically when someone makes a
straw man discussion it's easy to sort
it out if you have the information you
cannot in fact be there's no such thing
as critical thinking without hearing
uh things that differ
if you only hear one viewpoint by
definition there's no possibility let me
give you an example of this so so
they're saying that we wanted to let the
virus rip
and that's a lot we never wanted to let
the virus drip we wanted focused
protection of the old
um the washington post every single time
they published an article with with uh
with
talking about the great barrington
declaration had would have a quote from
fauci saying uh
that this the strategy was nonsense and
that uh that
we want to let the virus rip they never
asked me to reply to that they would
just
as boilerplate put let the virus rip
it seems like journalists have a
responsibility to try to get the story
at least the other side of the story i
mean they can put vouchers aside but let
me answer
yeah i just one quick observation and
then a question so i think that uh just
given the term uh they fight the fight
the war against the virus and the fight
i think from the very beginning there
was an analog to war
to a war situation rather than to
managing
an emergency and you know we all know
what happens in war and you know
everybody's you know striving for
consensus you cannot uh question
anything and i think i'm coming from a
country that had a lot of wars i was
born in israel and i i think that that
was an analogy that can explain the
mentality and also many of the things
that you talked about what i wanted to
ask though is
you know the base the infrastructure of
science are the
universities and
one of the things that disturbs me is
how universities behaved not only in
terms of
what scientists
expressed what opinion scientists
expressed or didn't express but rather
that then how they manage themselves and
their students and to to a large degree
universities were maybe the most extreme
manifestation of all of these bad
policies they they actually went to
remote studies
for for the longest time possible other
than a few exceptions
they are now mandating
boosters
to the lowest risk population
from the disease and the highest risk
from side effects even for people
that will recover 30 days later they are
mandated
to be vaccinated then i i have to say
i'm i'm personally i'm asking myself
very tough questions
at home and my one of my conjectures is
that universities are not managed
anymore by academics and by scientists
they are managed by lawyers
that just say hey that's the cdc
guidelines without
that's how it operates so i wonder what
is your perspective on
that i mean so like a couple of notes on
this so universities sent
they call them kids they probably
shouldn't call them kids our young
adults home
in spring of 2020
one of the big problems of focus
protection is multi-generational homes
right you have older people living
together with young people
we created multi-generational homes out
of whole cloth by sending all of our all
of our university kids home um i called
them keep calling them kids
people always tell me like yeah
yeah that's true
but but the but i completely agree with
you the the the policies of the
university have followed have nothing to
do with science
it's a form of group think like each
university is copying all the other
universities they're not referring to
science to justify their actions and
their the key thing is they want to make
sure that no one dies of covid in the
university it's fine if they dive covet
outside if they die it's fine if they
kill themselves it's fine if they if all
kinds of bad things happen to their
education
they've failed in their mission and it's
and it's not it's the it's the top
universities that have failed in their
mission the educational mission the
research mission the the commitment we
have to the the young adults in our
charge we have failed in all of those
missions
i can add one quick thing which is uh
people don't know this because it's been
scrubbed from the internet but october
2020
the cdc posted a paper on the damage on
their policies about schools i i was in
washington in the white house at the
time
and the cdc said quote it is unethical
to require testing of students if they
don't want to be tested unquote
now that doesn't even go toward forcing
vaccinations
to help these people young people who do
not have a significant risk for serious
illness in experimental vaccine
but they even have forced testing even
though the cdc itself in october 2020
said it was unethical
the point is we have had a breakdown
of the ethical
leadership
of young people and a moral breakdown in
the united states not just by closing
schools
but by forcing vaccines that are
experimental
that have known side effects
on young people
who are healthy and have no
no significant risk of a serious illness
if as a society
we're going to claim we need to
vaccinate children to use them as
shields for adults that is a complete
break
in the moral contract that we have
as human beings to our children
you are the shields for your children
your children are not meant to be
shields for adults
gentlemen it's a pleasure and honor so i
make a quite a brief observation and a
question the brief observation is that
i'm an economist and i look at you
and you're all surprised because maybe
for the first time or for a rare time
one of the precise scientists science
says suddenly
the mental is taken and we see how
politicizers
if you talk to economists sociologists
literature department
everything else has been cleared
of any alternative thought of any
alternative thinking of anything that
doesn't follow the party line long ago
so you know you're surprised because
because of the nature of your work
you've been shielded from this complete
uh i don't know what to call it you know
monochrome construction and i'm also
from eastern europe so i spent the first
part of my life on the
similar system so i'm particularly
aggravated that
these things start to look a little
familiar the question though that i have
for you is we all understand what was
the situation here in 2020 the political
context how the whole bureaucracy the
whole monopolies they were all
against
certain politician and certain group and
everything would work in unison
so my question is how these log downs
happen around the world in a sense every
country is an interesting separate case
did they had a similar political
structures do they had the same the
similar
uh censoring how i know that sweden had
a little bit different different but you
know for example
let me reveal it i'm originally from
bulgaria so these little stupid eastern
european countries they're all saluting
eu and doing whatever they were told to
do pretending that they have local
experts which they didn't have any
so a lot of damage was done to these
much weaker economies in the name of
life and all this emotion so do you have
any views of how
different countries because of their
institutional frameworks and their
political politics maybe was not so
dictatorial when we were not so
political maybe they did it better than
with us thank you
why don't you talk about swedenborg yeah
why don't you talk about that well
sweden was very different i think and it
was a huge contrast to see it living
here but still following the news in
sweden and every time i
thought well it's completely crazy here
i read the swedish newspaper for uk but
it's one place in the world there's some
sanity
and i think it's not just sweden because
all the scandinavian countries sort of
have had a fairly similar
policy with among the lowest
amounts of lockdowns as well as now
after two years
among the lowest cova mortality and the
lowest access mortality
and there was a discussion in sweden
because those who opposed those who
wanted to lock down more
they had some powerful people
arguing the case including academics and
the editor-in-chief of the sort of
equivalent of
new york times in sweden
[Music]
but if you go to other european
countries i think in the uk it was very
similar in a sense to the us
[Music]
if you go to like
uganda i think the schools were closed
for two years
[Music]
so uh there were many countries who sort
of followed the leads of i think the u.s
and the uk
and i know if i can add that that is i
think that's my perception there's
there's
a a massive influence
of the western countries we cannot
underestimate it's not just that the
united states
is economically intertwined and
therefore if we lock down the u.s
there's a chain reaction and the western
european countries
everyone in the world suffers
when you have the head of the u.s effort
get on tv almost every single day for a
year
talking about lockdowns
and when you have the united states
federal guidance
that was
lock down businesses shut schools
restrict don't see your families don't
see the older people don't even go into
the hospital if you're ill
when you have people like dr fauci the
most visible person on the task force
during the previous administration
and the head of the whole effort now and
dr burks was the task force medical side
director
when they get up on stage with the
president united states or next to the
president
and they put that out there and it's on
tv and in the newspapers all over
these other countries don't just say
we're going to do what we want i i don't
i think that's sort of not the way it
works i may be overstating the influence
of the united states but i don't think
so
they still quote
what dr fauci is saying in these other
countries and given that the statistical
modelers that
martin can talk about a lot better than
i can
in the uk
started this whole thing really
and in the us and they were so wrong
their models were proven wrong grossly
wrong making false assumptions but those
things were put on for some reason on tv
and there was just a
herd mentality
and the influence of the united states
public health leadership
in my view is to blame
for what happened in the rest of the
world to some extent
we were told at my university that we
couldn't come to work uh to do our
research because if it was non-essential
nobody likes to hear that their work is
not essential so i i converted my lab to
a sars kobe 2 wastewater covalent
surveillance
and
for the past year and a half i've
generated troves of data on on virus
transmission using wastewater and one of
the things that i've realized is that
you know you can plot these data and
superimpose when mask mandates are put
in or fines or whatever those things and
get a really
amazing picture of how effective those
policies are using wastewater and so i'm
wondering if you are
if anybody's doing this on a bigger
scale like i've been doing it for my
community for san luis obispo i can
and i am
you know i've gotten in trouble for
saying some of the things that i have
but it's grounded it's science it's in
in and it's grounded in poop
and and and the transmit the
transmission data that i'm seeing
and i'm just wondering if you've if
you've
seen anybody
if anybody's doing this this kind of
work looking at wastewater and
correlating trends and wastewater
virus loads to
certain so you know interventions that
have been used so there was a new recent
new york times story i don't know if you
saw uh where the cdc admitted to hiding
data hiding information one of the
things that they admitted to
to not really revealing is was their
wastewater surveillance
um i mean they
the idea that the premier
public health agency in the united
states is like hiding data
i just i can't write my mind around this
right like that we basically we
basically are owed transparency by this
your work and the work of others who are
tracking the the the the uh
the the spread of the virus efficiently
they i mean has gotten no attention
because
i think again it's the same thing they
wanted to create this illusion of
consensus this illusion of their control
of the science anyone who's on the
outside well you don't you're just on
the fringe
um and i think uh
if think just imagine how much better we
would have done if we'd had all our
minds all the minds of people
contributing this discussion in the in
the normal way like we would have had a
lot more fights but it would have we
would have ended up in a much better
place i think
no oh sorry he's next and then there's a
microphone there oh sorry yeah
so we worked on a little paper very
early on uh looking at whether the ihme
model was calibrated and so we were the
ones that said you know the 95 confident
intervals control you know cover the
next day
20 of the time that was us
so we sent it to a journal
and of course you know
we're not gonna we're sorry to tell you
but we're not publishing it yada yada
and then in the middle of the paragraph
was
we don't want people to be complacent
so you can you know parse that
however you want to parse it and then
they kept going so it was like this
non-sequitur sentence right in the
middle right in the middle of the of the
thing i i don't know to this day every
day i think about that sentence but it
seems like these journals were really
uh guardians they thought themselves as
guardians of the universe and basically
that's can i ask were
oh yeah yeah he gave him 400 million
dollars okay yeah he gave that place for
it you can't actually see the journals
can i argue with that i mean
like so there's a there's a couple
things there like one is that um
uh
early in the pandemic actually even now
there was this this idea that if you
came out with a result that that
underplayed the lethality of the virus
that you were going to cause people to
act irresponsibly
neil ferguson the the guy who did the
imperial college model famously gave a a
uh an interview where he said that that
uh it it was fine if he got it wrong in
the right direction if you over predict
it
the irresponsible thing is to get it
wrong in the in the the wrong direction
under predicting but in fact the when
the world health organization said in
the early days of the pandemic that the
death rate from the virus is three or
four percent they're talking about the
case fatality it's a very misleading
number
versus what what your real true risk is
if you are exposed to the virus and as
martin said there's a thousand-fold
difference by age the if if are you are
you underplaying the virus if you tell
people truly if you're young your risk
of dying is low
i i just
it's it's a
it's a use of science to control people
the behavior of people that has no place
in scientific discussion
and i'm i mean i i would love to see
your story written up and told because
that is that's it's absolutely shocking
right well it's not shocking to me
because i remember you sent me your
paper and you said this is back in i
think spring summer 2020
april
and you said i can't get this paper
published
and yeah i mean this is an example of
the internal sort of there's two types
of censorship going on here one is by
science itself the journals the
universities the nih the powerful people
and then there's another type which is
the media and the media
is the pathway of course the interface
between the public and the science
journals regular people are not going to
look up
the science publication so the media is
so critical and when you have an
interface that is the filter and the
is somehow the imprimatur of scientific
truth uh telling martin koldorf
that you know he doesn't know what he's
talking about about the vaccines
uh
we're in a very dangerous place and so
this is one of the things we're going to
try to do with peer review here there's
a there's a
a need to get more rapid publication
with accountable peer review or less
obstructive peer review
uh and we and you know it so
the solutions are not obvious but we
know the problems are very very profound
and we need to fix them
kind of vain
when i'm very grouchy in the morning i
think is there any way we could audit
the journals i mean let's take you know
a journal and let's look at the papers
on covid that were accepted and let's
look at the papers that were rejected
and let's check
and let's get the comments between the
editors um you know about the about the
papers you know that that would really
uh i think that's kind of a johnny
united kind of
a project but uh
you know that's something
you know
excuse me he's over here yeah
aaron if we got you next time
you mentioned you were at the white
house in october 2020. i'm wondering if
you can shed some light on and why it
was that president uh trump and maybe
his advisors didn't have any of you
people advising him instead of dr fauci
well uh
you know i was called i detailed this in
my book i want to bore everyone with all
the details but
at the end of july and asked if i would
help the president
and so i said yes
okay because there is no other answer
it's my country
when i got there
i was shocked at what i saw
because the people on the task force on
the medical side
were incompetent didn't know the data
and concerned about self-protection and
threatened when i would walk into a
meeting with 12 or 15 scientific
publications
and go through a little mini soliloquy
of the data
and they had nothing
except you're an outlier they would say
and they will go to the media
and what happened the question is what
happened uh really why there was a
somehow we diverged into a country
where we have our leaders have abrogated
their responsibility to lead by saying
oh that's the cdc guidance
that's what fauci and burke say
they were given
the authority
as opposed to just
being there advising
and letting the people in charge have
the authority and so now we have somehow
a cdc that is taken as a a law issuer a
rule issuer that's not what the cdc ever
was intended to be it gives guidance
that's it
but that's not the current situation
the second point i want to make is i did
view myself as an advisor that was
needed to bring in the experts who knew
what they were talking about and they
were actually doing the research and so
i set up a meeting and brought in martin
koldorf j bottacharia joe ladapo
and others people from stanford and
harvard and ucla and uh tufts university
and we met with the president
and the people on the task force
specifically that meeting was scheduled
so dr burks could attend
dr burks withdrew from the meeting right
before it it happened
didn't want to
have the discussion with people doing
the research
that's not the mark of a scientist okay
science is the debate science is being
able to know the material enough
so that you win on the basis of knowing
more and if you don't know more
your opinion doesn't carry the day
and so we met with president trump and
the next day we met with
the five of us
of the people met with vice president
pence
and then later i brought in dr gupta
bhattacharya and kaldorf to meet with
secretary azar because secretary azar
wanted to hear answers to his questions
and so we did the best we could but the
bottom line was the authority over the
federal guidance to the pandemic
was given
to doctors fauci berks and redfield and
today that continues
because it is given as you've heard
our current president say many times
whatever the cdc says whatever dr fauci
says and that is the uh really gross
uh malfeasance
of leadership in my opinion
so this will actually be the final
question of dr carriat yeah so there's a
follow-up
i think this problem of the relationship
between science and political authority
is a very very difficult one
all of the solutions seem to be in a
sort of all or nothing
extreme direction and i've thought a lot
about okay what what created that
and
it seems to me that the political
authorities are going to anoint some
scientists or group of scientists to be
you know in the current climate the the
experts that we're going to listen to
and unfortunately you've
dr atlas you just named the ones that
were anointed and we all know sort of
the results
of that but
i think one of the challenges is the
answer to most scientific questions is
nuanced right the great barrington
declaration is
is nuanced in the sense of is covid you
know bad well it depends are vaccines
good or bad are they helpful or
unhelpful well it depends it depends
your age group your risk categories all
of these nuance nuances which
um you know at the at the journal club
at the medical school we discuss and get
down into the weeds on
politicians don't really seem interested
in that they want something for the
stump speech they want an answer
and especially early on in the pandemic
when the media was focused on covet case
counts and covet death counts
and state by state comparisons there
seemed to be this kind of
my medic rivalry between governors to do
more and more extreme measures like i'm
you know i'm i'm seen as doing more to
address covet if my lockdowns or
you know my policies are sort of
more extreme
and
so but my question has to do with
how can the nuances of science actually
interact with the more binary
or all or nothing sort of policy
tendencies
that you know people who are looking to
get
re-elected or or the media i mean i
think this has to do with the media as
well right
you get 60 seconds to do a sound bite
and it's hard to it's hard to get a lot
of nuance in that context how do
scientists interact with those systems
without compromising
what we should be good at which is
subtlety
i think go ahead i think public health
and political scientists have no choice
but to trust the public
if he wants to be trusted it has to
trust the public but honestly say what
we know
but i honestly say what we don't know
um
both of those things
because what's happening is that public
health cdc says something which then
turns out to be wrong
nobody's going to trust tdc then
so the only the only way forward is to
be honest
even those things that we don't know
about
and it also requires courageous leaders
okay we do have people in this country
who looked at the data
and made a decision
that use logic
i mean i could point to several of them
one that everybody talks about is
governor desantis
we all had i had conversations with
governor desantis since the spring of
2020.
we've all appeared on panels and had
many conversations this is a person
who makes it his business to know the
data
and then to make a common sense
assessment of what needs to be done and
he's been proven right
okay he did better
than a lot of states most states that
did the lockdowns and better than my own
state of california on a data-driven
analysis
and so you need people who are not
afraid and
you know i once wrote a book
in my pre-health policy life called
magnetic resonance imaging of the brain
and spine
and i never i always thought there's
there are people who don't really have a
brain but i never knew how few people
had a spine
[Applause]
aaron can i address one one one thing i
thought you said is quite important uh
you you have to have scientific advice
like if you're a leader you you just
have to like you can't expect political
leaders to all have read the scientific
literature this is not realistic
the key thing is that the scientific
advisors
they cannot be in a position to silence
the rest of the scientific community
so that they themselves are seen as the
science like that you cannot have a
scientific advisor who goes around
saying thinking that if you challenge me
you're not simply challenging a man
you're challenging science itself
right that that that is uh
that that is i think that that hubris
has been a key part of the failed
response to covet in the united states
and elsewhere
so is there a selection bias toward
those who are sort of
more all or nothing or lack nuance
because that's what some of the
politicians want like if you bring your
hands too much and say well on one hand
or on the other hand they're not going
to call you again
do you know what i mean you know scott
scott has a very good way of just
distilling
scientific nuance into a compelling way
you can hear him when he speaks right
there's a reason why presidents speak
speak with him i think there's a skill
to that but scott is also open to
reading the literature and
we'll have scientific art you've seen
you know scientific arguments well i
mean
to be honest i i called these guys and
johnny and edie's every day every other
day for nine months straight
uh and so uh because you need to you
need to hear people's opinions
we all can read we've all reviewed
papers we've all reviewed grants we've
all submitted these things
but you need to hear what people think
and bounce things off of people that is
what is the the essence of really coming
up with the right answer
i think martin said something very
important too
the information
is needed not just for the public and to
trust the public and that is but it's
also needed because that's why i brought
in a bunch of other people to talk to
the president the presidents these
politicians they need to hear it they
need to get enough divergent
opinion so that they can be critical
thinkers because it's their
responsibility
and so uh
i think that the again it all boils down
to the lack of censorship the
transparency of information and that
that really is the sort of most obvious
solution to most of these things
okay
[Applause]
i guess
final 30 second thought from each
panelist starting with martin and then
we'll finish
dr koldorf pardon me
uh
well thank you all for coming here and
for listening and i think
the role of the task
of
restoring trust and restoring
in public health and science is
something that we all share
so i hope that's something that we can
all do together
both everybody here as well as many
people around this country and around
this world we have to do this together
yeah i'll sort of echo what martin said
i want to thank everyone for
understanding the seriousness and the
the really the urgency of the problem
here the country and the world
was harmed significantly
and we can't let that happen again
and so i'm very delighted that so many
people accepted our invitation to come
here also for our event tomorrow i must
say that there are still people who said
they support us but they wouldn't come
tomorrow they're afraid
so this is a problem that is very
serious there's no quick solution
but it's going to take
everybody's effort
and more and more people to have some
sort of commitment and courage
and eventually
with a wide sort of population basis of
getting something good accomplished we
will do it because it will not come from
top down all these things these changes
have to come from bottom up people
so i just want to thank each of you
that's come
from many of you i've learned during the
pandemic i've read some of your papers
i've uh
frankly you give me hope that scientific
discussion science is still alive
and i've doubted that sometimes
during the course of the pandemic
i think in order for science to to have
uh to revive to be what it really should
be it's it's in badly need of a
reformation
right a re-establishment of
of
the the norms of the enlightenment
that uh
to me it has darkened during the
pandemic um and i think uh this
this effort
you all that are in the room are i i i
know will be a big part of that reform
and re-establishment of science as a
force for good in this world
well and let's give them all a hand of a
pause
[Applause]